okay little nausea has kept our heads
turning in look
after look
after luck
[Music]
as one of the next generation's biggest
style stars the rapper has been pushing
fashion boundaries in his music videos
live performances and on red carpets
now we can't talk about androgynous
fashion without a nod to billy porter
his christian siriano moment at the 2019
oscars will forever go down in fashion
history and he's been one to watch on
the red carpet ever since as we see
stars like harry styles kid cudi and
jared leto continuing to push gender
bending style forward it's queer fashion
icons like billy that have helped pave
the way
from bella swan to lady die kristen
stewart has had an evolution for the
books and her fashion is no exception
as a chanel ambassador since 2013
kristen has been turning heads on red
carpets for years in looks that
perfectly combined french couture with
her own edgy aesthetic
janelle monae has challenged fashion and
beauty standards for a minute
as a staple of the best dressed list
time and time again it's no surprise she
took home the board of directors tribute
at the 2017 cfdas
[Music]
and canada's own dan levy has been
serving david rose vibes on and off
shit's creek can you imagine this in
prison from valentino to tom brown to
custom level dan levy has become a
fashion icon in the last few years and
we can't wait to see what looks he rocks
next
[Music]